welcome to a new week of news and
politics in the united states i want to
start today by
trying at least to run some interference
and introduce some facts into the wild
disinformation really is what it is
disinformation and ignorance and talking
points that are spreading
about crime in the united states because
there there are actually some i believe
well-intentioned people including people
on the left
who are are falling for some of these
talking points and are
ending up in places where they certainly
shouldn't be and one of the things that
can become difficult particularly right
now is that one of the techniques that
the right uses
is to continually you could say move the
goal posts you can say to gish gallup
which is just to throw a whole bunch of
stuff out making it hard to refute
each piece but if you did refute each
piece you would realize
there's really nothing there and the
area where i'm going to focus on today
is crime
because in the wake of the george floyd
protests in the context of
calls from some on the left to either
defund or abolish the police in a
broader context where
most of the left wants to reform you're
starting to hear
all of these subsequent steps being
taken to get to
joe biden will cancel all police and
your kids will be killed as a result of
it right like that's where they want to
end up
there's all these intermediate steps and
one of those steps is
crime is going up there's more crime
right now and
they talk about this in the context of
portland and chicago often by playing
you know 30 second clips of this or that
thing happening so we
we absolutely have to go step by step
so first and foremost if we're going to
talk about
whether defunding police once joe biden
does it
we'll do x or y to rising crime rates
we've got to figure out is that actually
joe biden's plan would
such plans if they existed actually be
successful but most importantly is crime
going up right now and crime rates in
the united states on a year-to-year
basis have been declining that is
the first fact we have to introduce here
because the entire conversation stems
from that
despite the fact that we have more and
more people living in the united states
over time
actual crime rates for things like
violent crime robbery property crimes
it has all been declining on a per
household basis
when you survey people and you ask them
do you
think crime has increased in the united
states from last year
almost every year more than 50 percent
of the people in the united states
believe that yes
crime has actually gone up so crime has
been going down
since the early 90s people mostly
believe
crime has been going up okay that's step
one
now there are a whole bunch of other
details and
complications that warrant some more
exploration so let's do a couple of them
before we move on
for example some types of crime might be
up one year
even in the midst of a downward trend or
some types of crime might be up one year
even when other types of crime are down
so as an example
in 2020 murder is up slightly but a
whole bunch of other crimes
are down and over time all of these
types of violent crime
are down so you would have to decide can
i really make any relevant observation
in one year about well murder's up
but rape and robbery are down and arson
is up but
burglary and sexual assault or whatever
right so
overall crime rates have been declining
for a long time and they continue to
decline
it's also important to remember that not
all crimes are reported to police so
anytime we're looking at something that
depends on reporting to
an authority you have to consider that
the records
may not reflect reality at equal rates
so as an example which many on the right
don't like
sexual assault is notoriously
under-reported
however that doesn't really fit into
their narrative if they want to make it
seem as though crime in general is
under-reported you really have to start
with sexual assault which they don't
seem particularly willing to do
then you have other crimes crimes like
vandalism and public intoxication
which arguably should not even really be
a crime which
certainly are visible in that you see
graffiti or a broken window
or with whatever the case may be but
those are not the serious violent crimes
that we're really mostly talking about
when we talk about how police should be
reformed
so that gets us to what's going on today
since the george floyd protests have
started
we've been hearing uh defund the police
we've been hearing abolish the police
we've been hearing reform
we've been hearing just fund the police
blindly give them as much money as they
want we've heard every combination of
things
the majority of the left including joe
biden
is talking about reform uh it could
include reallocation of funds taking
funds away maybe from militarization
while
increasing funds for training as one
example but
it doesn't really matter in terms of the
crime we're seeing now because remember
all of the discussions about defunding
abolishing restructuring
all that stuff it's in the future it
hasn't happened yet and yet still you
have people like donald trump himself
and his acolytes tweeting videos of
things going on now
in uh you know portland or chicago
saying
this is the future of the country if joe
biden is elected president
hold on a second first of all that's
trump's america right now
so to say this is what's going on now
and this is
what would be happening even more under
joe biden you then have to see
does what is it that joe biden would do
that would exacerbate this and there
actually isn't anything
but it also ignores that none of these
abolish or defund things have become a
reality so
they are arguing we are seeing more
crime in cities
because police have been defunded by
democrats the reality is crime continues
to go down
and nothing's been defunded yet there
have been some conversations in certain
places about
how might we reduce funding to police in
some places
you know northampton massachusetts is a
place where the show started where
there's been this discussion
there's been a decrease to the rate at
which police funding will
increase if that makes sense um but
all of this stuff is in the future so
you certainly
can't blame a future
possible changes to police funding for
current increases in crime particularly
when there have been no such increases
today
there have been discussions about do we
change who responds to certain types of
911
when they relate to homelessness or
mental illness as an example okay
those discussions have been had there
are some places that have started to
look at making some of those changes but
these policies haven't yet been put in
place when it comes to defund or abolish
i don't think that they are going to and
joe biden certainly doesn't
uh support them so when you look at this
broader context
you do have to ask why are people
falling for the idea that crime is up
and this actually takes me back to my
days as an undergrad at the university
of massachusetts amherst
where uh michael morgan who's been a
guest on this program
studied this extensively eric ashar
also studied this and both of those
interviews are on the youtube channel
there's often this assumption and we see
it after mass shootings we see it after
a lot of things
that violence in the media and in
popular culture in movies and video
games
makes people act violently in the real
world
now by and large that doesn't seem to be
true
it if you look at the scholarship on
this it's certainly possible that people
already predisposed to be violent in the
real world
might be triggered to act um in a
particular way
based on things they consume in violent
video games or movies but that's a small
small portion of the population by and
large we have not
found that violent video games or
watching violent news or
or whatever makes people violent in the
new in the real world
however what does seem to be the case is
that seeing
violence on the news and in media may
make
people more afraid and it makes people
believe
that the world is more dangerous than it
is and in fact
when you look at local news and you
realize wow murder is down over the last
30 years all of these violent crimes are
down over the last 30 years
but the representation in media is
identical or has even grown because of
this if it bleeds
it leads ideology it makes sense that
based on watching news people would
believe the world is more dangerous than
it is people would believe there is more
crime
than there actually is so what you have
right now
in part thanks to the trump
administration uh
is this use it's all based on getting
trump reelected and we're going to deal
with that a little bit more later in the
show
you have a lot of discussion of very
rare
individual incidents that are happening
in the shadows of mostly peaceful
protests but the takeaway we have to
remember
is that crime rates have been on the
decline since the 90s and there
certainly has been no defunding of the
police yet
which you could blame for non-existent
crime increases that they claim exist
now one other thing that i think is
important to think about
and that's the war on drugs and prison
populations
some will say clearly there is more
crime
because people are in prison for
committing crimes more than ever before
there are more people in prison right
now so clearly there's more crime going
on
just because there are more people in
prison doesn't mean that the streets of
the united states are more dangerous
from a violent crime
standpoint if you add things to the list
of stuff that will get you put in prison
you would expect that more people are
going to end up in prison
if you put in place mandatory minimums
or if judicial discretion is used
to sentence people to longer prison
sentences
you can see prisons more full even
if violent crime is on the decline in
general society
which it is so it's really important not
to fall for that propaganda
because at every level there there is to
go back to the beginning there is a gish
gallop going on
where a whole bunch of stuff is thrown
out crime is up
and it's crime because it's up because
police have been defunded and joe biden
would do more of that
you've got to break it down is crime up
no uh
have police been defunded already in a
way that would even relate to what we're
seeing right now
no does joe biden want to defund the
police if
if he becomes president no every single
one
of the premises is wrong and they count
on
because they don't have the facts on
their side side they count on you not
knowing the facts
or you not checking the facts and ending
up having to argue on the merits and
when we accept the facts
and debate what should be done we're
missing the fact that the premises are
all wrong hopefully this is useful when
we see
everything from don jr's tweets to
discussions in right-wing media
and on the internet about these issues
go and look at whether the premises make
sense and check out in this case
they don't starting with crime has been
on a downward trend
for decades in the united states let me
know what you think i'm on twitter at
deepakman
we have a lot happening this week this
is the month
of the 15-year anniversary of the david
pakman show can you imagine that and
i'll talk to you later on in the month
about
what we're going to do the exact date is
in the second half of the month
uh but a very very exciting month we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the show and the start
of what uh i am sure will be another
insane week in american politics today's
new david pakman show members of the day
are jean-jerome casalonga thanks john
jaron for your membership also
francisco cuevas we might call them paco
in argentina or in a lot of
spanish-speaking countries but
thank you francisco really appreciate
your support and also
george sores is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day george has
been a member
uh incredible for almost five years
right now
and you can sign up support the work
that we are doing it's cheap it's quick
it's easy and it feels good it really
does
at joinpacman.com some things are really
complicated in the world and in politics
and they require deep knowledge they
require speaking to experts they require
understanding different disciplines and
considering
uh a lot of different components nuclear
energy
string theory post-modernism whatever i
think you understand
the right amount of taxation to balance
um not uh properly funding social
programs while not disincentivizing work
or whatever right there's
there's a lot of complicated stuff that
exists in life
we have a really simple grand theory in
front of us which explains donald
trump's behavior as of late and it
doesn't require
uh this deep and and nuanced knowledge
of anything like string theory or
taxation he is terrified that people
that you
i'm talking about people like you are
going to vote in november
and more specifically he's terrified
that you are going to vote for someone
other than him
if you just look at the last two three
weeks in american politics
just about everything that donald trump
has done publicly
relates to that fear which has become an
existential fear for him because his
political life depends on how
you vote in november don't imagine that
it's about how
other people vote it's about how you
vote you
have agency in this and donald trump is
scared to death
his political life that you might vote
for somebody else
donald trump demoting his campaign
manager brad parscale
because he saw he was losing in the
polls and he reportedly was on the phone
furious with par scale and ultimately
par scale
is demoted that is because donald trump
is scared
that he's going to lose if brad parscale
sticks in
as his campaign manager donald trump's
new tone on coronavirus which lasted
like three days which included
you know carrying around his mask and
saying it could get worse before it gets
better
a more sort of somber sober tone
it was just desperation to turn polling
around his idea was let's just ignore it
ignore it ignore it open up pretend
everything's going back to normal
that failed he knows that the failure on
coronavirus is one of the main drags on
his approval rating
and so he takes a new tone that's all it
is and it only lasted about three days
trump opposing vote by mail because he
thinks vote by mail will hurt his
re-election
and it will i'm going to show you the
new polling data on that
trump correctly perceives if more people
vote by mail
that's probably not good for me it's
good for joe biden
he's right i will explain why so trump's
motivation to stop
vote by mail by which we really just
mean expanding accent
absentee ballot access his real
motivation is not oh it's going to be
fraudulent or fraudulent as he says
uh it's that it's just not going to be
good for him uh announcing that he's
banning tiktok could even relate to this
now will he ban tick tock
we don't know you know like like most
things we were supposed to get a new
health care plan yesterday we didn't get
it he announces many things that never
happen
comedian sarah cooper's videos about
donald trump
go giga viral on tick-tock and
they really don't make trump look good
it was tick-tock
users that allegedly organized that
coordinated mass ticket request for
trump's tulsa rally
which ended up with a two-thirds empty
arena so again going after tick tock
could be trying to look strong on china
it also could be that trump perceives
that
it's going to help him in terms of his
election to ban tick tock
kneecapping the post office by putting
in his
multi-huge millionaire donor as the
postmaster general
if people are going to be voting by mail
delay the delivery of the ballots by
hurting the post office
perfect strategy right every action is
in the context of how can trump get
himself re-elected
reportedly being open to help from
russia
china and either other countries and
we'll talk about that later today
there's a new interview there which is
completely out of hand
it's because trump is desperate that
he's going to lose and he'll take
anybody's help that he can get
and then in the end as trump realizes
that
some people are truly so committed to
his removal
that they would crawl over broken glass
and dodge landmines to vote to remove
donald trump
he floats the idea last week of delaying
the election
now i have to tell you i wish i was as
confident
that trump was going to lose as trump
seems to be that he's going
to lose in the sense that you would only
do all the things donald trump is doing
if you were pretty reasonably sure that
you had a good shot at losing this thing
so while publicly trump says we're doing
great in florida
we're doing great in florida both of
them uh
et cetera he knows that really he's not
doing well and he knows that he may well
lose
and i am not as confident as trump seems
to be that he is going to lose
over the last seven days some polls have
tightened up in trump's favor now it's
he's still behind
but it's it's still you know five weeks
to the election i'm sorry no
uh we're still two months uh three
months to the election i'm getting
confused
we're four and a half weeks from the
first ballots being cast but we're still
almost three months from the election
three months to the day
um you don't want to see polls start to
tighten now that's a bad sign
now everybody has a different idea about
what drives donald trump and i got some
emails over the weekend saying you know
trump's worried that if he
loses in november he's going to end up
in prison
i actually don't think that he's worried
about that because i don't think there's
really any chance that it's going to
happen and i know that i continue to
hear from people who say
trump's going to get indicted for this
trump's going to get indicted for that i
don't think so i think that there will
be
some financial crimes for which
his companies maybe will be held
accountable with fines but
trump's not going to prison and anybody
waiting for that i think is going to be
waiting for
the rest of their lives this is simply
about
donald trump's narcissism donald trump
trump's delusions of grandeur
and the constant power trip that he is
on he doesn't
see himself as a loser and losing is
you know to use their language losing is
a beta
i don't think trump in practice even
wants to be president he wants to be
president
in theory in terms of the power that
comes with being the president of the
united states trump is a cornered animal
who perceives a threat right now he has
the fight response rather than the
flight response the flight response
might be
i'm going to resign or turn things over
to mike pence or whatever
before uh this goes bad in november if
indeed that's what's going to happen
trump has the fight
response and we know from studying the
animal kingdom that this is dangerous
territory to be in all of his actions
from now
until november should really be
interpreted under this framework and we
just can't let him do it it's actually
that important
and uh the numbers that we now have
relating to vote by mail versus vote in
person
are a huge signal
about why on that issue trump is digging
his feet in the ground sticking his head
in the sand drawing a line in the sand
whatever metaphor or analogy i'm mixing
up here you all know what i'm talking
about
and deposing vote by mail let's talk
about that next
so we've already discussed today that
donald trump's actions on just about
every issue
everything we see him do publicly it's
motivated at least partially by does it
hurt him in november or does it help him
in november that's the lens through
which
all of these decisions are being made
about carrying his mask around
about canceling the huge event of the
republican national convention all of
this stuff is just what's the calculus
in terms of how it affects my election
when it comes to vote by mail we just
received
some stunning new polling data from
emerson polling
and if this data doesn't convince you
that trump knows
exactly what he's doing by opposing vote
by mail and confusing vote by mail with
absentee voting
as if they're two different things this
data should convince you
that he knows exactly what he is doing
paul's subjects were asked in this
emerson polling
survey who they support trump versus
biden
and grouped by whether they plan to vote
in person or vote by mail
of those who plan to vote in person
65 percent support trump and only 32
percent
support joe biden of those who plan to
vote
absentee 76
support joe biden and only 20
support donald trump so put it a
different way trump leads two to one
among voters planning to vote in person
and biden leads
almost four to one among people planning
to vote by mail
this is why trump opposes vote by mail
now
the thing to understand is that this
split
between in-person versus vote by mail
is not partisan per se it's health
related
let me explain what i mean we know from
other polling
that republicans are roughly half as
likely as democrats
to wear masks all the time when they
leave their house i think it was
something like
roughly 66 to 33 or you know 66 percent
of democrats were wearing a mask all the
time outside their house
only 33 percent of republicans or
something like that
what this means is democrats are taking
the pandemic more seriously
the reason that biden supporters are way
likely way more likely to vote by mail
is they are taking the risk of catching
coronavirus more seriously than
republicans
now you could come in and say well if
there's more vote by mail open more
trump supporters will vote by mail
if there's less vote by mail open biden
supporters
will just go and vote in person it's all
going to shake out evenly
that's exactly the wrong approach
that is exactly the mistake that's being
made in analyzing this
biden voters are more likely not to vote
at all if they can't do it safely
while trump voters are more likely to
vote in person
if that's available if that's all that's
available so
sure most biden voters planning to vote
by mail
if they are told you can't vote by mail
they'll put a mask on
they understand the importance they'll
go and
take the risk because they understand
the importance of the election
but if you believe as is probably the
case that there are
some biden supporters who might not vote
at all if they can't vote absentee
you then try to stop vote by mail
altogether which is exactly what donald
trump is doing
imagine that if you take some state that
could be close
and you restrict cancel or stop vote by
mail and it dissuades just three percent
of the total electorate from voting
and imagine that in that three percent
who will say
if i can't vote by mail i'm not voting
at all imagine that
80 of that slice would have voted for
biden
and 20 of that slice would have voted
for donald trump that can flip a state
that it it literally is enough to flip a
state let's look at wisconsin in 2016.
now
trump won wisconsin in 2016 very
narrowly trump won by about 22 000 votes
in 2016 in wisconsin if you dissuade
three percent
from voting that's about 83 000 people
that you would dissuade from voting
maybe if you say you have to come in in
person
if eighty percent of those dissuaded or
biden supporters
and twenty percent of those dissuaded
are trump supporters
canceling vote by mail grows trump's
victory by
50 000 votes now the margin was only 22
000. so understand how
a small portion of the electorate if it
is
mostly biden supporters being dissuaded
from voting
could flip or put a state out of reach
now this is a hypothetical example with
hypothetical numbers
the point is blocking vote by mail
even if it affects a small percentage of
total voters
based on this data it would
disproportionately hit
biden supporters and it could turn a
state so when you combine
trying to prevent vote by mail with
kneecapping the post office which is
what donald trump is doing right now by
having selected
one of his donors to be postmaster
general
you can actually turn states and that's
why you know when we see
okay one poll has biden winning by 15
it's not going to be 15
another poll has biden winning by 10 but
when you account for the margin of error
it might only be six
if that six becomes three or four by
election day
if you strategically slow down the mail
in some states
and stop vote by mail in other states
a three or four percent popular vote
victory for
joe biden might not be enough to
actually win electorally with hillary we
know 2.2
as a or 2.8 2.2 as an as a popular vote
win was not enough to win electorally
because
of 77 000 votes in three states we could
see that again
and this is why anybody who's looking at
the polling and saying we we got this
we got this biden's up 15. biden might
only be up six or five when you account
for the margins of error
and that could very quickly become an
electoral college loss because of
exactly
this stuff do not become complacent is
the message
continue uh we will continue our
coverage of this on the david pakman
show instagram page
at davidpakmanshow follow me on
instagram
for my latest argentinian food delivery
from this weekend got some really great
stuff empanadas of course
of course empanadas i'm david.pakman on
instagram we'll take a quick break and
be right back
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
welcome back to the david pakman show
if you want to talk about a story that
is
pure evil i mean just pure unmitigated
immorality it is this breaking story
from vanity fair that donald trump's
son-in-law jared kushner abandoned or
decided never to build the national
coronavirus testing program
because of the political calculation
that the coronavirus seemed to be
hitting blue states and not red states
and their plan was jared kushner's
infinite wisdom was
let's just allow it to run its course in
in blue states
and will blame democratic governors this
is according to just a blockbuster new
report
in vanity fair as always with the trump
administration it's not
just immorality it's also incompetence
because as we now know
the 20 top hot spots in the country
other than california
are all in red states so not only was it
immorality
it was also a miscalculation that this
thing wasn't going to spread to red
states now
understand people died because jared
kushner said
the virus is in blue states we'll blame
democratic governors we don't have to
really build a testing program
we wondered early on well first of all
really early on we wondered why jared
kushner even had a role in the
government
but okay i mean early on in coronavirus
we wondered why aren't we building a
testing program january 20th roughly
within hours of each other
the united states and south korea got
our respective first
cases they immediately built a testing
program
as well as a tracing program as well as
fever clinics to isolate people
and south korea had one of the best
responses to coronavirus in the world
while still ranking higher than the
united states on the democracy index it
was not some
a wild authoritarian response in the
united states meanwhile
we didn't develop testing cases started
to climb
confused messaging we don't want the who
test we're developing our own test but
our test development failed
meanwhile south korea had already
essentially gotten 90 percent of the
control
of the virus done and we still didn't
have testing and the rest is history and
we're about to have 160 000 people dead
as a result of this virus
eventually the trump administration
started claiming
we did have testing we have the most
tests in the world
we have the best tests in the world all
of those lies which we know
to be lies but there's still this kind
of question mark of what happened in the
middle was it
merely trump saying let's not do
anything because i don't believe this is
going to become a big deal
was there a calculation of some kind and
vanity fair's report
is very specific the kushner team which
had been put
shockingly i mean that the fact that
there was a kushner team running this
is a major insanity but the kushner team
decided
let's not do a national testing program
let's start with
this is in blue states this is the job
of governors
and then we will say this is the fault
of democratic governors look at how
great these republican governors did now
why did they do it well if you looked at
the map in early april
the virus was mostly in blue states
right the early hot spots were
the new york city area including new
jersey
california boston was an early hot spot
chicago illinois and of course
the early hot spots were the places with
a whole bunch of direct flights
to china and to europe the early places
that were sort of the sources of
infection for the world
so their idea was their gamble was they
thought it's going to stay in blue
states this is going to be a blue state
problem it was dumb to think that of
course if you understand
virology at all but that's not kushner's
area of expertise
and so they said let's just let it run
let's not develop a testing program
it'll be great politics because we'll be
able to say look at the failures of
these blue state governors
vote republican in november now it's
backfired in two ways
it's backfired politically it's
backfired
from the point of view of health which
is of course the real tragedy so first
politically
it didn't stay in the blue states and in
fact this has been the major
issue that has destroyed donald trump's
approval in addition to the economy
which relates to the virus and trump's
handling of race issues those are the
big three
but the virus is the biggest on which
you see a large gap
between how do you believe trump handled
it and how do you believe
biden would have or will handle it so it
backfired politically
but more importantly because i care
about
people in terms of health not developing
a national testing program early led
to way more cases and way more deaths
period now
there's a lot of people continuing to
tweet stuff
like trump's not responsible for 160 000
deaths
of course not who's saying that the
point is
there are plenty of deaths which are
extra
unnecessary deaths due to the federal
government's handling
just look at just about any other
country very few countries have done
worse than us in terms of response
and so that delta the delta between this
is a global pandemic and some people
were going to die
and the number of deaths we have which
is now 160
one estimate says it could be 300 000 by
the end of the year i mean it's bad
we're getting up to 1500 deaths a day
again uh
some of that is attributable to i guess
now we've learned it's jared kushner
to blame for the non-testing decision
now a more important
question is what is the number of people
that jared kushner's protocol
led to no longer be alive and i want to
be really clear right like
they decided to let it rip they decided
to let people die
because it was a political calculation
they miscalculated
it they thought it's going to kill
people in blue states and then we'll
blame democratic governors
that didn't work out so that's a
dystopian
dystopian nightmare but it's actually
even worse than that because
you know we there's that phrase hanlon's
razor is an aphorism
never attribute to malice that which is
adequately explained by stupidity
earlier we thought that what was going
on was just stupidity or
primarily stupidity we are now learning
that it was malice this is
actual malice the allegation made in the
vanity fair article is
just let blue staters die they could
have done testing but they chose not to
shouldn't someone go to prison for this
people are asking about oh you know
should kushner resign
resign he should be in prison and by the
way
he was never elected he was never
confirmed he is certainly unqualified to
even be in this position
and he made the decision
to allow people to die for a
miscalculated political gain
now we've talked about like a little kid
trump deserves a consequence for what
he's done
the consequence is being voted out in
november because
nothing else is going to happen jared
kushner
is also up on that list of deserving a
consequence but i really want to be
clear here
this also is on trump one of the maybe
misguided reactions to what we've
learned about jared kushner here
is kushner is solely to blame trump
picked kushner
and to some degree the buck stops with
trump right i mean trump all
of obama's presidency was tweeting time
after time after time
the buck stops with obama so the buck
has to stop with trump here as well
i hope people are are understanding that
so
this is another scandal that in the
midst of
a dozen others is getting one percent of
the attention that it deserves
what happened to russian bounties i
don't know what happened to the new
health care plan that donald trump
claimed was going to be signed into law
yesterday
there's nothing i guess it's every
single day
and it has to stop and this is i mean
this
is now a type of evil that goes far
beyond incompetence and
i i subscribe to hanlon's razor much of
what we've seen during the trump
administration
has not actually been malicious it's
been indifference
it's been maybe negligence but it's been
led by incompetence
this is now a very specific allegation
of not incompetence but
actual malice and they must suffer the
consequences
we're never getting back the people that
died as a result of jared saying
it's mostly in blue states let's let it
rip instead of developing testing
there is a stunning new poll
out of the red state of georgia in which
democratic presidential challenger joe
biden
is winning against donald trump by one
point
this is absolutely and completely insane
and probably not indicative that biden
is going to win georgia
and i want to talk about that in a
moment there's actually a lot to talk
about here
and this is really going to get us into
a discussion of the role of polling
going forward from now until november
3rd
the last time let's start in georgia the
last time that a democratic presidential
candidate won georgia was 28 years ago
was bill clinton in 1992
it was a squeaker bill clinton winning
by
0.5 percent of the vote over george h.w
bush but notice if you're watching that
there was a third party candidate ross
perot
who did get 13 of the vote in georgia so
the last time that a democrat won
georgia
without a significant third party
candidate was
1980 40 years ago when jimmy carter
defeated ronald reagan
but that was jimmy carter's home state
so the last time stick with me here
that a democratic presidential candidate
won georgia
in a two-way race when georgia was
not their home state was 1960
when john f kennedy defeated richard
nixon brutally 62-37
that was 60 years ago so
when we see a poll today that says
biden's winning by one in georgia
to me it's a signal that it could be a
bad november for trump
it's not really a signal that biden's
going to win florida the average i'm
sorry georgia
the average in georgia is still trump
winning by 1.6
but the important thing about the latest
cbs news poll
which has biden plus one is that it's
using a likely voter model instead of a
registered voter model and i've talked
to you before about the importance of
this
if you just survey adults that's
considered the least accurate because
half the country doesn't vote if you
survey registered voters it is
considered more accurate because you're
at least restricting
the poll to people who are registered to
vote many registered voters don't vote
but it's more accurate than just all
adults because many adults just aren't
even registered and they never vote
likely voter is arguably if done
correctly
the most accurate and so that's a good
thing that's a good sign that as we
start to see registered voter models
become likely voter models as we close
in on november
the polling should become more accurate
that being said this poll
that has joe biden winning by one in
georgia has a 3.4
margin of error so what that means is
the poll could actually be in reality
biden is at 42.6 and trump is at 48.4
like that's what the margin of error
means so
this poll which has biden plus one could
actually be
trump plus six and be within the margin
of error so what that means is
we should take nothing from this other
than
everybody's gotta vote whether you think
your state will be close
or not you've gotta vote i do not
believe trump will win georgia
but if enough polls say it's tight maybe
trump has to spend money there maybe
trump has to campaign
uh two georgians that's a victory
getting republicans to have to spend
money
in georgia in texas etc
that's a good thing so the big picture
of this
sort of battleground and moderate rates
red state polling is that trump is now
according to new polling losing by four
in north carolina
losing by one in georgia there is some
texas polling that has trump down
the meaning of it is this is a really
bad presidency
that's the takeaway given the hyper
polarized nature of the country right
now
when you look at these traditionally red
states and you see that it looks like
it's close
that means that there are some partisan
right wingers that are realizing this is
so bad that i'm at least as of right now
not yet committed to support donald
trump uh you know
maga will be maga trump will still get
tens of millions of votes that's an
indictment of our country no doubt
but there is actually some reason that
is
in injecting itself embedding itself
in the brains of some committed right
wingers but we can't forgive the
ignorance
if our population had been better at
critical thinking
and had done 10 minutes of actual
research back in 2016
trump never would have been the nominee
and certainly never would have become
president of the united states many of
the unnecessary coronavirus deaths that
we've had
would would not have happened and that
number is likely to hit 160 000 in the
next day or two so what we want to do
here is understand what's happening so
that it doesn't happen again
starting with this november but we can't
forget how it happened
we can't ignore that it could happen
again and it still might happen again
in november if we don't vote so to go
back to georgia for a moment
it's not just that there's a margin of
error and trump might actually be
winning like that's one one
interpretation would be
okay biden's plus one but you look at
the margin of error
could really be trump plus six that's
that's one part of it
the other part of it is when you look at
the history of voter suppression in
georgia
when you look at the planned voter
suppression in georgia
it should give us zero confidence that
these close
states are even going to have a shot at
going our way
unless we completely overwhelm the
voting
in november so it's a sad reality
there's a lot we're up against right now
and it includes
five or six different ways in which
donald trump is going to try to suppress
the vote
we have to accept it and work with it
and what that means is
so overwhelming voting turnout and every
every election both sides say it we're
our side's motivated we're going to have
record turnout and very often
particularly among some voting groups it
doesn't happen
we actually have to do that to overwhelm
trump kneecapping the post office
voter purges limiting vote by mail and
on
and on and on that's the only way
forward
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your chemex or french
press or
a david pakman show t-shirt it's all
available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
davidpakman.com
gear don't miss the bumper stickers too
davidpakman.com
forward slash gear
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
sometimes in the political analysis
space we over analyze
obvious things and then other times were
under exposing major stories
and then sometimes it's sort of both at
once and that's the case here
top trump adviser went on tv yesterday
and three times refused to deny that the
trump administration was or would
uh accept was accepting or would accept
foreign campaign assistance and
opposition research on joe biden and
then ultimately ended up sort of saying
well we're not accepting it right now
without actually saying we would not
accept it this is both a major story
that should be 110 exposed but it's also
a completely obvious
position of the campaign that requires
no analysis because it is exactly what
donald trump has been saying for months
or years that he would do so let's take
a look
here is jason miller trump campaign
advisor
we've seen clips of him before wacky guy
interviewed by chris wallace on fox news
sunday yesterday and this is the first
attempt from chris wallace asking
has the trump campaign received
information from foreign groups or
nationals on joe biden
or joe biden's family uh will you
accept it if it were to be offered this
is the first shot
at getting an answer to the question can
you
state flatly that neither the trump
administration nor the trump campaign
has received any information from
foreign groups foreign nationals about
either joe biden or his family
and can you state flatly that neither
the administration nor the campaign will
accept
foreign assistance chris that's a silly
question i mean the folks who have
actually taken foreign assistance were
the clinton campaign
four years ago i mean that entire shady
dossier they put together
was from a british spy uh no we're going
to go and beat joe biden
fair and square here absolutely but i
think you should have asked the same
question to do with his prospective
running mates and senator duckworth and
karen bass because just as we saw
four years ago it was the democrats who
took foreign assistance
so look at the specifics of what jason
miller says it's a silly question well
that's not a denial
it was democrats who did that that's not
a denial
we're going to beat joe biden fair and
square trump has already said he
considers
uh at least checking out foreign
opposition research as
being okay so therefore in their mind
it's arguably fair and square to do
exactly what chris wallace is asking
about so chris wallace tries again
here's a second time but
can you flatly state that the trump
campaign and the administration will not
accept foreign assistance this time
chris i said that's an absolutely silly
question we're going to go and win this
race
fair enough i'm just asking for it for
an answer
again not a denial this isn't that tough
right
jason miller says for a second time
that's a silly question
we're going to win fair and square trump
believes
it is fair to win with foreign
opposition research so chris wallace
is right to be skeptical of the way that
jason miller
is answering these questions let's now
back up a few seconds
and then we're going to hear the third
attempt and the third
sort of non-answer uh we're going to go
and win this race fair
i'm just asking for it i'm asking for an
answer it's a it's a yes or no question
jason
chris there is no foreign assistance
that's happening in this campaign but i
would ask you
to make sure that the democrats aren't
going to do what they tried to pull four
years ago
because that's exactly they're going to
try to find every possible way
to cheat and steal this election 100
there
is no foreign assistance that's
happening now again that's not a denial
that they would accept it and of course
this is laying the groundwork for
if later it's discovered that the trump
campaign
did accept foreign opposition research
or info
they can hide behind look miller said
that at the time they hadn't received
any and maybe at the time that was true
and they could argue a technicality but
this this really is a big deal
but it's also not shocking in that
donald trump admits this donald trump in
that
infamous interview with abc's george
stephanopoulos about a year ago i think
it was
might have been was it may of 2019 i
don't even remember when it was but
roughly in the last year or 15 months
donald trump said to george
stephanopoulos yeah
i would look at stuff from russia i
would look at stuff from china sure why
not
so jason miller can't really say no
because trump has already said yes
publicly that's the crazy part of it his
answer to
can you categorically and definitively
say
that you won't accept foreign help is
it's not happening right now and it's a
silly question
not particularly convincing now also
there's this focus from them
on democrats doing it that's a new
talking point you heard it used there by
jason miller
asked about what the trump campaign did
is or will do
um saying well it's democrats who
actually did it you know christopher
steele the dossier
democrats don't need foreign assistance
for information on donald trump
democrats
don't even need really domestic
assistance because trump has done it all
anything and everything you can imagine
in the light of day and that's why
i i'm sort of both optimistic and
preemptively depressed
if we can't beat trump given what he's
done in the last three and a half years
in a sense the country deserves trump
for another four years i mean i i don't
i don't know how to say it
if trump cheats to win right if the will
of the people actually is for trump to
be defeated
and trump cheats to win that's different
but if in a fair and square election
this guy gets re-elected
on balance tens of millions of us of
course don't agree with it
but on balance don't we deserve another
four years if after all this we don't
remove the guy
something i've been thinking about a
donald trump over the weekend carried
newspapers around like a prop
this was advanced damage control for an
interview that's going to be aired
tonight
during which donald trump is confronted
about whether he reads and there are
about
three different angles to this story the
primary angle is
we are getting crushed on coronavirus
due to trump's failed response
and he's still golfing all the time
trump golfed on saturday
and he golfed on sunday he was
supposedly signing a new health care
bill into law
yesterday sunday he golfed instead no
new health care bill
but on top of it trump continues to be
concerned with the optics of carrying
around newspapers rather than actually
doing something about coronavirus so
let's go through it
saturday trump golfed and he was spotted
getting out of his vehicle
carrying just a whole pile of newspapers
he also had a really strange bruise on
his hand which led to new speculation
about some medical issues but that's
that's not even the focus
today but trump had this pile of
newspapers that he was carrying around
now we've been care covering trump's
reading for years
and it would not be news to many of you
but because of the russian bounty story
trump's reading is back in the news and
in an interview coming out tonight with
axios jonathan swann
trump is confronted about whether he
reads does he read his own presidential
daily briefings and part of the reason
why
is that as far as multiple reports have
outlined
trump was briefed multiple times about
the russian bounty stories
although trump is claiming that he was
not
and so in this interview we got a clip
of it last week it's publishing tonight
donald trump claimed that he has the
best reading comprehension
of anybody that jonathan swann had
interviewed here's that clip from last
week they released a preview of
tonight's interview
i wouldn't mind if it reached my desk i
would have done something about it
it never reached my desk because do you
read your recent brief i do
i read it a lot you know i read a lot
they like to say i don't read i read a
lot
uh i comprehend extraordinarily well
uh probably better than anybody that
you've interviewed in a long time
i read a lot i spend a lot of time with
at meetings
so first of all when your president and
people
don't even believe that you read things
have gone
very very wrong there was no reason to
question
that barack obama read a lot george w
bush
didn't have to like him i didn't like
him but he read
i think it was like a book a week or a
book every two weeks there was no
question that these former presidents
read
trump doesn't read and as far as we know
he hasn't read an entire
book a cover to cover in his entire
adult life
but trump always goes to f too far he
doesn't just say i read
he says my reading comprehension is
better than anyone you've interviewed
recently
what what does this have to do with who
jonathan swann
has interviewed and likewise now the
calculated
advanced damage control of trump being
photographed with newspapers also goes
too far
he's carrying a gigantic stack like if
we were to believe that trump looked at
one newspaper
okay maybe but the idea that trump is
reading a stack
of newspapers on his ride to play golf
is too silly to even be plausible
everything is posturing everything is
pretense and optics and
if anything trump is looking at the
pictures in the newspapers maybe he's
looking at like a headline or two
the bible he clearly doesn't read it he
said it was his favorite book along with
his own book
now there's another side to the story
that i want to briefly mention
there was a ton of speculation that
trump went to walter reed hospital over
the weekend
uh for either unknown reasons or is a
supposed cerebral event
and that the bruise on his hand in the
picture is from having an iv
um and that the newspapers were actually
just meant to kind of cover the bruise
which didn't work
there is no evidence that that's what
happened the white house says he didn't
go to walter reed
you know that when things have been
fishy with trump's
medical status i've told you about it
until we get actual evidence that this
is what happened
it's much more likely that trump just
wants to be seen holding newspapers to
create this idea that he reads
knowing that tonight there's a major
interview believed to be very damaging
to donald trump being published by axios
during which the topic of trump's
reading comes up i think the simplest
explanation
is the accurate explanation here and uh
if we get other evidence to the contrary
you know i will be here telling you
about it we have a voicemail number
which you can call
anytime that the mood strikes that
number is 2192
david p here's a caller asking
okay okay okay maybe trump is not likely
to delay the election but
if he does who becomes president it's a
good question take a listen
david hi i just wanted to call and
give you a little bit of a correction on
something you said
last week when you were talking about
trump's insane tweet about
delaying the election you said that uh
if the situation were that we didn't
have an election by january 20th
that nancy pelosi would become the
president united states because trump's
term would expire obviously mike pence's
term would expire
um that first part is right their terms
expire but
the second part is not actually nancy
pelosi will also be
on the ballot and her term expires a
little earlier in january
if there's no election so she the entire
house would basically be
empty if there were no election and so
nancy pelosi would actually not be the
president united states the president
states would be
who's third in line which would be the
president pro tem of the senate
um 86 year old after actually 87 when he
um
by that time chuck grassley so
that will be chuck rashly president
um an entire house that is completely
vacant
and a senate that is a third vacant base
so there's actually
it's actually even more complicated than
this so first of all
it is conceivable imagine that so
the election is really 50 elections
right each state
runs an election um it doesn't appear as
though trump can just delay the election
from the federal level but he could ask
governors to delay state elections
it could happen that enough state
elections are delayed
such that there's no winner in the
presidential race
but california might have their election
and nancy pelosi
could win so it's actually from what i'm
reading conceivable
that you might not have enough states
running elections to have anybody get to
270 electoral votes
but if california did their election
it's theoretically possible that nancy
pelosi would
be elected to another term but let's
actually play let's imagine
that the house is vacant okay it would
not be chuck grassley what would happen
from my understanding and i went over it
with producer pat today a couple of
times
um there are a bunch of senators who are
up for re-election
and it's two it's one-third of the
senate
they would all those 35 seats would all
be vacant so you would have 65
senators left because republicans have
way more seats to defend right now than
democrats
the 35 seats that would be open would be
mostly republican seats
this would put the senate back in
democratic control
at which point they would vote on who
becomes senate pro-tem
and usually they go with the most senior
senator which would be vermont senator
patrick leahy so so it's actually
even more complicated if the election
were delayed
and nobody there were no no elections at
all
the senate elections don't happen that
leaves 35 senate seats vacant the house
is vacant
okay the remaining 65 senators who are
more democrats than republicans
vote on a new senate pro tem who becomes
president
by history that would be patrick leahy
knowing that the person would become
president
maybe they would vote for someone who's
younger than patrick leahy i don't know
but it's like two layers more
complicated even than that
and hopefully it doesn't come to this i
don't believe that it will i believe we
will have
a presidential election we have a great
bonus show for you today we are going to
talk about the new republican-backed
heels act we'll talk about what's going
on in the nba
we will talk about canadians sneaking
i'm sorry
americans sneaking into canada in boats
yes we are now the ones doing that
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
you